from remarkable women to impressive
young gals take a look
jaya patillo she's just 12. she's got
her eyes on a huge prize the 2024
olympics in paris look at her run
this is training video of her 17 miles
per hour
uh-huh it went viral after espn put it
on tick tock
and now more than 100 million people
have seen it
we're started at like 12 or 13 and then
we had planned on stopping at
15 but my coach said it looked like i
was jogging so we went up to 17
and he said i could win up to or i could
have went up to 18.
my gosh i go 3.9
jaya is no stranger to sprinting she's
already a nine-time
junior olympian and her dad says he knew
early on she was destined for the track
she's got mom's backing too i would hear
jaya running and i happened to look at
her legs
and her legs were not just walking but
they were striding
and at that point i knew that she would
be a runner we're just here to support
her and be there to make sure that she
gets
as far in life as she wants to go jaya
trains several days a week
tries to stay grounded despite racking
up multiple awards and medals and of
course being an honor roll
student wow